What does it mean when my AST is elevated?
So AST is an enzyme, it's in the comprehensive metabolic profile.
That's what you're going to see it.
Or maybe times people will just get a liver panel done at their medical doctor.
And AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase are considered the liver enzymes.
But in truth, those enzymes are in other tissues too.
So AST is going to be produced in more highly metabolic tissues.
Your muscles make AST. Your liver, obviously, your heart, your kidneys, your lungs,
when you have low AST, typically that's a vitamin B6 deficiency.
So we don't see that very much.
So most people, you know, you don't have to be taking vitamin B complex or something like that
to be getting your B's. If you're eating vegetables, even good meat, you're still getting
your B vitamins. And you're not going to end up with some gross vitamin B6 deficiency.
But it does happen. Some people have really bad gut absorption sites for your B vitamins.
Some people's diet has been really poor. And they can't end up with vitamin B6 deficiency.
It can be a vitamin B6idemia is a real thing. It's just not real common.
Most of the time, you're looking at elevations of AST. That's what this question is.
So obviously, the first thing you think of is liver. So when AST and ALT are elevated together,
especially with alkaline phosphatase, the first thing you're going to think of is liver stress.
But in truth, it's not always the liver. You could have AST elevated with early congestive
heart failure. So again, remember, any blood test is a clue. And it's a clue that should get your
doctor to ask other questions. You know, and I'm trying to get you guys to think like a doctor here.
So I have elevated AST. What does that mean? Could be my liver has got issues. So there's other things
you'd look at too in conjunction with that. Again, like ALT and alkaline phosphatase also elevated,
well, that it's more probable that it's my liver. If my GGT, which is another test, is elevated,
then I would think that it's maybe outside of the liver. So again, AST can be elevated with
congestive heart failure. But then you're going to look at and decrease CO2 level. So CO2 is
another test that you would see in a comprehensive metabolic panel. And then you'd also look at LDH,
which is a typically the comprehensive metabolic panel. But LDH is another thing if your person
has congestive heart failure, LDH can be elevated as well. Same thing with cardiovascular issues.
If you have cardiovascular issues, AST can be increased. ALT can be increased with cardiovascular
issues too, but you'd have an increase in CO2. And typically an increase in uric acid with cardiovascular
issues. But most commonly people are going to think of liver dysfunction with AST. Plus it depends
on what your current health issues are. So if I know I have cancer or let's say I know I'm taking a
medication. So again, one of the most common causes of liver congestion, liver issues, liver
dysfunction is a medication that you're taking. So if I'm taking a medication, even like a
fenmedazole or an Ivermectin or Tylenol. So Tylenol, remember, statistically in America there's
15,000 people a year on average that die of Tylenol toxicity. What is it? What's Tylenol toxicity?
Have you ever heard of that? Well, of course you don't hear of that because they're listed in
their autopsies and die in a liver failure because it causes liver dysfunction. Their AST, LDH,
it's possible basically through the roof, the liver is shut down and the person died. So that nobody
ever said that it's from Tylenol, but you can look up at the annuals and it is from toxicity,
from Tylenol, and over the counter medication. So medications are the number one thing that causes
liver issues because they're, you're taking them in quantities that it's very difficult
to detoxify. So it has been measured that different medications detoxify on different pathways
in the liver. If you already have, you know, issues with your NAT1 pathways, which a lot of
meds detoxify other different cytochrome P450 pathways, you have genetic defects on those pathways.
And then you're taking these meds, it's going to be difficult to detoxify them and it can't
overwhelm those pathways and it can damage the liver cells. And that's what liver failure is.
So you will see a spike in AST and ALT and typically alkaline phosphatase if that is the case.
Problem is, if you're not doing blood tests on a regular basis and you're on these medications,
well, how do you, how are you going to know? That's why I ask if you're going to be on
a medisol that you're doing a regular comprehensive metabolic panel so we can keep an eye on things so
we're not seeing any spike. Plus, you could have an allergic reaction to a medication that can cause
liver failure. So we get more complicated. So you want to keep an eye on these. You don't do these
blood tests just for no reason. You do these blood tests so we can see if there's damage,
if the liver is being compromised in any way. So those are the things that you look at with AST
elevated. You compare them with like any blood test, any specific individual marker, you compare it
with other markers to get a differential diagnosis and then you use other tests as well.
Based upon the clues that you get from your blood work to give you data to dig deeper to figure out
the reason why you're always looking for the reason why. And to me, it's a very shameful thing when I see
people's blood work and it was ordered by their doctor and the doctor never went over it. So it's
why is your order then? I don't get it. So that's another